and now I'd like to present mr. Warner
Brothers pictures from the institution
of the same name my good friend and
current landlord Jack L Warner thank you
Bob
it was just 30 years ago it was my
privilege then as one of the founders of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences to be present at the very first
Academy Awards through the year these
selections have come to represent the
voice of the industry and the
recognition of excellence in the making
of Motion Pictures and tonight it is my
privilege to present a gentleman who
personifies that industry the
distinguished president of the Motion
Picture Association of America mr. Eric
Johnson
wherever he lives
whatever is native tongue
there is one language for which a school
boy needs no interpreter a
motion-picture it is the most best and
most useful eraser of international
frontiers that has yet been devised
certainly that fact is amply shown in
this year's nominees for the best
foreign language pictures it is my real
pleasure to present to you tonight this
winner but first I think I should tell
you who the candidates are
they are Harry and the butler the bent
Christiansen productions from Denmark
the immortal love so chiku company from
Japan animus to Han Yeol the important
man película s' ro decrease from Mexico
Placido jet films from Spain and through
a glass darkly spence k-- film industry
from sweden now the winner is woo
through a dark to a glass darkly from
sweden
Harold and Boozer
and we only wouldn't win it you remember
that I'm sorry that in my is not here
I mean mr. Bergman but then he just
started to write this no new pictures of
then he never leave the country thank
you very much from him